and this is fox news alert welcome to
Hannity on this busy breaking news night
we start this morning before sunrise
heavily armed FBI agents dressed in full
tactical gear surrounding the home of a
66 year old man drawing their weapons
pounding on the door and they took him
into custody now this was not a
suspected murderer drug kingpin not a
part of the mob no this was Roger stone
accused of making a false statement to
Congress stone is just the latest
American to be persecuted by Robert
Muller's witch-hunt because of his
connection to President Trump now coming
up tonight longtime Roger stone
confidant and fellow mulher target he's
identified as person number one in this
indictment jerome corsi
he will join us for an exclusive
interview but first big news we start
with the partial government shutdown
President Trump announced today that
after 35 days a deal has been reached to
reopen the government temporarily until
February the 15th he is given Congress
now three weeks to agree on legislation
to build the wall secure our borders and
he was speaking earlier today from the
Rose Garden and here's what the
president had to say it's just common
sense walls work that's why most of the
Democrats in Congress have voted in the
past four bills that include walls and
physical barriers and very powerful
fences these barriers are made of Steel
have seeped through visibility which is
very important and are equipped with
sensors monitors and cutting-edge
technology right in our Hannity watch
segment we have the real
behind-the-scenes story nobody else in
the media will tell you
numerous Democrats both in the House and
the Senate for the last two weeks they
have been speaking to their Republican
colleagues they have been asking them to
broker this three-week opportunity to
support the wall and negotiate other
parties like another issues like daca
and dreamers they've been begging their
Republican colleagues to make that deal
with the president so the president well
he showed leadership rose above the
partisan bickering in the swamp off
in relief to federal workers all while
sticking to his commitment to secure our
border now the president was very clear
no ambiguity in three weeks if Congress
cannot do their job secure a deal to
protect our borders then the president
will do what he lawfully has the right
to do and that's declare a national
emergency and he will be building the
wall with funds that he allocates most
likely from the Defense Department
this is indeed a real crisis in three
weeks he will declare a national
emergency and look at what the
president's done up till now he's
offered concessions things the Democrats
say they wanted daca dreamers TPA he's
standing up for life versus death to him
he's been arguing safety and security
for the people of this country but
tonight we have to ask ourselves this
question what are the Democrats what are
the Nancy and Chuck been standing up for
actually nothing
there's no position here they have only
been placating what is now the radical
extreme base of the socialist Democratic
Party of today and all they do is fuel
their daily anti Trump rage and hate ask
that question of tonight Democrats what
did they do they went on vacation the
president stayed at the White House
luxurious junkets really paid for by
lobbyists while the president stays at
the White House refusing invitation
after invitation to sit down with the
president who's saying I'm willing to
work with you I'll work on doc I'll work
on dreamers but we've got to secure the
border to save the lives of our fellow
countrymen because of the problem with
open borders now these other Democrats
privately they have been going behind
the leadership in their own party asking
leaders like Lindsey Graham and others
hey help us get this period where we can
try to get this job done they want the
wall as well but they're just not
telling Schumer and Pelosi if not they
know the president will declare that
national emergency now the president to
his credit he has tried every single
thing he could possibly do he has been
reasonable
he has been fair he's offered
concessions but in the end it's his job
as commander-in-chief to keep us safe
he'll do his job
so now Congress they have their three
weeks to do their job and secure our
border Democrats we need Republicans
they need
remember the facts that we have built so
far 654 miles of border wall over the
last 15 years with notable results for
example the wall in Yuma Arizona after
it went from 5 miles to 60 Plus miles
well that led to a 91% drop in crime
remember Democrats they actually used to
be for strong borders just a few years
ago that's when Obama was president
actually they sounded more like Trump
than Trump before they were consumed
with all this anti Trump 8 and rage
every day
take a look people who enter the United
States without our permission are
illegal aliens and illegal aliens should
not be treated the same as people who
entered the US legally to so many
Americans we do not want the wall to be
a symbol of America much preferring the
Statue of Liberty be that symbol all of
us agree that we need to have
comprehensive bipartisan immigration
reform that can only begin strong border
control we must have that we must
control our borders morality it's not
who we are as a nation walls work but
we've got to finish the job I've said so
many times on this program the cost of a
porous border they're enormous and it's
growing more serious every single day
human trafficking drug trafficking gangs
cartels it is a life-and-death situation
talk to angel moms and Angel dads talk
to the parents that have lost their kids
because of the opioid crisis and then to
make matters worse another ten thousand
person migrant Caravan right now as we
speak is headed our way so you say
tonight to Chuck and Nancy all right
behind your back your fellow Democrats
they want that wall they also want to
deal with daca they want to solve
problems they want solutions will you
work for it now you can either work with
this president do what's right for the
country or the American people will see
you for who you are
just obstructionist hating a president
and anyone out there by the way thinking
president Trump cave today you don't
really know the Donald Trump I know he
right now holds all the cards he will
secure the border one way or another and
what President Trump works hard to solve
serious issues of life and death
facing the country well we do have
another issue tonight Hannity watch on
the deep state robert muller and his
merry band of democratic donors they
continue their quest literally to
destroy the lives of everyone and anyone
that's associated with Donald Trump
today Roger stone was their latest
target our own trace Gallagher has the
very latest on the pre-dawn raid on the
Fort Lauderdale home of longtime
president Trump confidant Roger stone
began with the FBI shouting opened the
door it ended with stone being led away
in handcuffs the seven count indictment
is the first criminal case in months
from special counsel robert muller and
alleges that senior members of the trump
campaign tried to benefit from the
release by wikileaks have hacked
democratic emails damaging to the
Clinton campaign stone called the
special counsel politically motivated
and vowed to fight the charges saying he
was falsely accused of making false
statements to the House Intelligence
Committee here's what he just said on
Tucker Carlson tonight watch I'm in for
the fight of my life but I will not quit
I will not fold I will not Bend I will
not bear false witness against the
president I intend to fight because this
indictment is is is fabricated this
indictment is thin as as can be White
House press secretary Sarah Sanders said
the charges don't have anything to do
with the president and Trump attorney
Jay Sekulow said the indictment also
does not allege Russian collusion by
Roger stone or anyone else meaning
there's no evidence that stone conspired
with WikiLeaks or the Russian officials
who the special counsel believes hacked
the Democratic emails the indictment
does say that stone repeatedly discussed
WikiLeaks with campaign associates here
he is again watch but knowing what's in
my email and my text messages there is
no corroboration whatsoever
for this and as for my email exchange
with Steve Benin everything I told him
in the exchange was publicly reported
information Stone is obviously out on
bail a 250 thousand dollar bond to be
exact his next court date is genu
29th in the nation's capital it's not
uncommon for the FBI to make
early-morning arrests of targets who are
under indictments but it's the first
time Robert Muller has used this tactic
stone had been predicting his indictment
for months Shawn back to you right race
thank you we are witnessing the biggest
abuse of power
scandal in modern American history is
playing out right before your eyes
more corruption than we've ever seen
really a pre-dawn raid 17 vehicles move
in 27 FBI agents and full SWAT gear guns
drawn home surrounded for what Roger
stones not being charged with any
violent crime here he isn't charged with
colluding with a foreign government at
all
he's never posed any security threat of
any kind and said he was indicted on a
series of processed crimes that never
would have happened yet Robert Muller
started an investigation this is in
other words created by the fact that
Muller had an investigation why is he
being treated like Pablo Escobar now
naturally fake news CNN they were there
they captured the whole thing Wow how
did they though the exact timing of this
somehow the network's fake news
so-called journalists know exactly when
and where the raid would go down and the
time it would happen well couldn't be
could it did one of maybe somebody in
Muller's office maybe one of the
partisan investigators I don't know did
they tip off their favorite fake news
network take a look
Allison it's it's reporters instinct the
whole Russia team thought maybe
something was happening there was some
unusual grand jury activity in
Washington DC yesterday we also had some
other signs that maybe something was
going on this angle the Roger stoning so
we showed up at his house this morning
we were the only ones there and lo and
behold
maybe another investigation into more
leaking the details of an ongoing
investigation by the way that's a
serious crime I wonder if these leakers
they ever going to face justice oh
that's right we're living in a two-tier
justice system one if you're a Clinton a
whole other one of your Democrat and
like virtually all the investigators on
Muller's team oh they seem above the law
but if you're associated with President
Trump you get your door kick down in the
middle of the night hauled away in
handcuffs
all while see it in films at all your
[ __ ] your feathered in the public square
your innocence is stripped before ever
facing trial your rights are trampled on
by a politically motivated army of
clinton donors you know what this bears
all the markings of Muller's so-called
pit bull Andrew Weissman and like all of
Muller's previous targets Roger stone
was not charged with anything Russia
involved no collusion no Russia no
conspiracy to steal Clinton's emails or
commit campaign fraud because he didn't
commit any of those crimes and isn't
charged with that that's why he's
charged with seven bogus processed
crimes again five counts of lying to
Congress and not once lying about emails
oh and text messages all of these crimes
occurring after the start of the Muller
investigation now this is nothing more
than a political persecution now let's
not forget James Comey he lied to
Congress John Brennan lied to Congress
James clapper lied to Congress on
multiple occasions are they going to be
charged when will they get the pre-dawn
raid treatment what about former deputy
FBI director Andrew McCabe fired for
lying to the FBI when is he going to get
the pre-dawn raid homies general counsel
James Baker while he leaked sensitive
information when is his pre-dawn raid
James Comey leaked Bureau memos to the
press via a close professor friend is he
going to get charged for that now the
biggest of all we have Hillary Clinton
she mishandled top-secret classified
material on an unsecured private server
and then you want to talk about
obstruction of justice not handing over
emails not handing over text messages oh
that's what they just charged Roger
stone with but Hillary destroyed
subpoenaed emails 33 thousand of them oh
then she washed her computer hard drive
with bleach pit and then they busted up
the devices was Hillary Clinton's
pre-dawn raid James call me Andrew
McCabe Sally Yates Rob Rosen Stein they
all lied to a FISA Court
they never
the veracity of the charges in the
Clinton bought and paid for phony
Russian dossier are they going to be
charged for those blatant crimes this is
sad and the this is now going to be the
end of real justice in America because
this is a two-tiered system of justice
and today after posting bail Roger stone
he remained defiant take a look I will
plead not guilty to these charges I will
defeat them in court I believe this is a
politically motivated investigation I am
motivations I have said previously there
is no circumstance whatsoever under
which I will bear false witness against
the president nor will
myself and according to the special
counsel the basis for stones arrests
surrounds his attempt to source Clinton
campaign emails acquired by WikiLeaks by
the way that's not a crime I've said it
before I'll say it again if trying to
access WikiLeaks information and find
out what they had is a crime then almost
every media outlet in this country would
be guilty of that crime in 2016 nearly
every paper every news organization
accessed WikiLeaks documents surrounding
the stolen Podesta emails including the
ever so loved liberal New York Times
they actually provided direct links to
the leaked emails inside of their
articles which brings us now to a
Hannity history lesson as it's very
similar to a case in 1971 a famous case
known as the Pentagon Papers when the
New York Times published a top-secret
federal report on the Vietnam War called
the Pentagon Papers the report was
stolen it was given to the times by
federal employees and subsequently
published by the New York Times and
various other papers and other news
agencies now following an attempted
government crackdown the Supreme Court
upheld the media's right to publish what
are stolen Pentagon Papers so Roger
stone or the New York Times or anyone
else was interested in knowing what
WikiLeaks was going to produce next
which have clear they all were and
leaked it and in other words the Clinton
emails in 2016 that is not a crime
unless of course they stole it or they
conspire to steal it which that is not
part of the charges that's why Roger
stone is only facing processed crime
allegations five counts lying to
Congress and as you can see robert
muller found zero evidence of criminal
campaign collusion but still wanted to
turn the screws anyway you know so maybe
he'll talk or maybe he'll compose or
sing
sound familiar why because muller wants
to take down a duly elected president of
the united states he has only democrats
donors on his team
they won't revenge for the 2016 election
and they appear to stop at nothing to
get it
but I have a newsflash for Team Muller
there was no collusion your
investigation is baseless always has
been and you will never subvert the will
of the American people